news we climb up the news tree to pluck
the good news coconuts
and with me at the desk is my trusty
co-pilot literally whether it's in an rv
at a desk ross matthew hi everybody
yes would you like to kick us off today
i would do because can you all believe
it but 2022 marks the 40th anniversary
of e.t yup yeah
so crazy does it feel like 40 years ago
that e.t came out
um i mean it does you know but not in a
bad way and like oh these last 40 years
have been jam-packed they have and
e-team means so much to so many people i
mean everybody here you know everybody
loves that movie
and
there's um
there's one super fan who loves the
movie and his name is john oliver who
we're obsessed with
and mashable reports that john oliver
just told jimmy fallon that e.t was the
very first movie he ever saw
and his parents had to physically carry
him out of the theater because because
he said he was screaming in tears
because he was heartbroken that at the
end spoiler alert elliott didn't go with
e.t
which is the ending he wanted to see
right
yeah yeah anything john oliver wants
i know can we can we redo the ending
when john is actually our neighbor here
at the studio and it's fun that we're
all co-workers because like you you
actually ran into him recently right
well no at the beginning when the
pandemic was first starting and we were
launching in september 2020 i was so
excited that the man i one of the men i
admire the most on planet earth would be
our neighbor but they were shooting from
a different location because of covet
yeah but i i think but didn't you run
into him in the hallways here well i
certainly did yeah and what happened
then
well
um
i i kind of yelled at him you kind of
yelled at him yeah you you know me i'm a
little rebellious and naughty i was
upset because i was like oh my god
you're supposed to be
my neighbor yeah yeah and you're in the
white space somewhere i don't even know
except except you were wearing a hat and
a mask so he had no idea
it was
drew i love him so much well speaking of
ever so exciting
is back uh bridgerton
but
i know we all love it
but i have some weird news to report
apparently people are a little upset
the new york post reports that some say
season two is missing two vital
ingredients
the hot and steamy sex and john reggae
pain yes
but what people are saying basically is
they miss him and the sex
now rossi have you been watching it what
thought yeah of course i started i had
to do my research so yeah i started uh
i'm on episode two and i even like put
my little finger on my ipad like this to
like fast forward to see if there's any
like naked
and
there's not okay it has lost that loving
feeling i'm still into the storyline and
the beautiful but nothing's giving me
that
hey like
jean-ray j
reggae oh yeah you know that it's a good
question because obviously this is not
appropriate for children but i would
feel weird watching bridgeton with my
friends you would oh yes well there's a
few episodes in season one there's you
should be alone when you you know what
i'm talking about it doesn't mean that
kind of alone but like i don't want to
be like what's up like we're watching
like
that is not like i don't know i i don't
even sleep in the same beds with my
friends i'm really weird
oh my god well i'm so turned on watching
maybe this is
maybe this is the problem now bridger
didn't you guys last season you always
talked about how watching that first
season of the show
really like lit a fire relit a fire
inside of you right
the sexy scenes yeah i don't think
season two is gonna do it i do that oh
god he's so
talented i have to say
[Music]